we talked about coming together to solve
our problems as a country this is one of
the best ways that we can come together
these predatory loans and high interest
rates impact rural communities they
impact urban communities like those that
I represent and and it's funny because
you would think that in a densely
populated community like the Bronx or
like Jackson Heights that you'd be able
to have a bank on every corner but what
we actually see is that in poor and
lower-income urban communities there are
way fewer banks per capita you know
there's a there was a study that showed
in Compton there was one think for every
25,000 people back in 2006 now it's from
Brookings and so it shows that it's not
just access to capital but just the
ability to go somewhere and cash a check
it can be very difficult whether you're
in a very rural part of the country
or even in certain urban neighborhoods
and you know we talk about payday
lending and in New York we were really
lucky in that we've we worked very hard
to outlaw payday lending in the state
but what happens when when everyday
banks start to charge higher and higher
interest rates essentially your credit
card becomes a payday loan and I this is
not anything radical because we had
these laws for a very long time in red
states we had them in blue states we had
them in half of the United States had
usury laws until 1978 when they were
repealed and ever since then and it's
given a blank check for credit card
companies and for big banks to charge
extortion level interest rates to the
poor and the reason this is a moral
issue is because we should not be using
people's misfortune and using people's
income status as a basis for extortion
and as a basis for predatory lending and
fifteen percent by the way is a lot
fifteen percent interest is a lot so you
run a bank you can continue to be
profitable but to charge 30 40 percent
interest rates is no less an extortion I
heard I heard from constituents in my
own district people have to take out
loans connected to our our horrible
state of health care in our inhumane
state of health care in the United
States that I was just sharing from a
constituent who had to take out a
$40,000 loan to pay for his mother's
cancer treatments and they gave him the
bank gave him over a 20 percent interest
rate so that he could pay for his
mother's cancer treatment so what
happens he was paying this was back in
2006 he was paying them completely on
time $800 a month he was paying on this
$40,000 loan to keep his mother alive
and when the financial crisis hit he
lost his job he was struggling to make
payments and without telling him they
sold his loan off to a different debt
servicer they sued him in court he got
no notice for it and then it wasn't
until his wages were getting garnished
that he found out that there was a
settlement for him to pay fifty three
thousand dollars on a forty thousand
dollar loan of which he had already paid
twenty eight thousand to keep his mother
alone to keep his mother alive and that
is legal and it is common in the United
States of America but it is not normal
and it is not humane I should add that
this year people in the United States
will pay a hundred and twenty two
billion dollars in credit card interest
and that is a 50% increase in just five
years so what you have got payday
lenders Oviatt which is beyond belief
that is just disgraceful beyond
imagination but you got all these guys
in their three-piece suits who are now
the new loan shark
hoodlums that we used to see in the
movies you know we've seen the movies to
cut off great on you cap if you don't
pay back well well I don't know that
they break kneecaps
take your home no that's right maybe
something even worse made me pull the
plug on your mom who needs medical
treatment so let's be clear about what
we're talking about we're talking about
economic brutality we're talking about
some of the most powerful people in the
world people who make millions and
millions of dollars a year in banks that
make billions of dollars a year in
profit and they see a real profit Center
in going after desperate people who
because wages have been stagnant for 40
years cannot afford the basic
necessities of life so today we're
telling Wall Street and the payday
lenders that enough is enough - you're
grotesque and disgusting behavior is not
acceptable in America and we're gonna
change it and this is an issue that
impacts zillions of people all over this
country and I think a lot of people
don't even know they go into a store and
they buy a refrigerator they don't know
that they're paying twenty six percent
interest it goes it just goes to show
that all of these issues are connected
and it all comes back to our pocketbook
when we see these these corporations
like Sears or like we saw with the
bankruptcy with Toys R Us is that these
private equity groups are taking over
these everyday retail companies and they
stopped being companies that are retail
and they start being essentially finance
companies so it's not it's not a
department store that sells you a credit
card it's a credit card company that
lures you into a department store and
that's what's going on look at it but
that's true in other words a very
significant percentage of the profits of
many of these departments was not
involved in selling you the product
they're getting significant interest
rates when you charge to buy that
product that is just quite amazing all
right well so I think it's it's also
important to connect the justice piece
to this as well because when we look at
how all of these things stack up and add
up they concentrate in rural poor
communities and
and urban communities and communities of
color as well when you look at mortgages
communities of color tend to pay much
higher interest rates on their mortgages
and we see that as James Baldwin as
James Baldwin said it's expensive to be
poor
stay on that point for a minute
everybody know what what she meant by
that and that's a profound point if
you're wealthy you have good credit
Murnaghan good income you go to the bank
you can borrow money at a low rate go to
a good grocery store in your community
buy food that is healthy and good not
too much
want to buy a car you buy it with low
interest rates if you're poor if you're
poor your interest rates are much higher
you live in a food desert so your
average head of lettuce or your average
you know bit of spinach is much more
expensive than it is in other
communities and all in all over and over
again you just think about I remember
when I was waitressing and I had a
checking account now with a lot of these
corporate checking accounts before I had
pulled my money out and and joined a
non-profit one a nonprofit bank what
happens is that you need to keep a
minimum of say fifteen hundred dollars
in your bank account for all 30 days of
the month so that you don't get charged
$25 for them to have the privilege of
holding your money and so you're paying
25 bucks a month just to keep your money
in a bank account and the average
American has so many Americans have less
than $1,000 in savings so this we're
talking about the majority of people
that have incurred a $25 a month charge
to just keep your money in a checking
account we're talking about even if you
try to avoid that charge and you take
your check to a check cashing place
which is very common here and in in my
community you take it to a check cashing
place they're charging you 10% just been
pushing sometimes six 10% to get their
future to cash a check it is expensive
to be poor and
if you can't afford you know a year ago
I didn't have health insurance
a year ago I was paying for all of my
medicine and cat